[Musik]
>> SALLY: Sehr verehrte Damen und Herren,
heute darf sich jemand wieder ein Rezept wünschen.
Wir sind wieder bei "Wünsch dir was".
Und dieses Mal stelle ich euch jemanden vor,
der wöchentlich zu uns kommt,
da wir gerade mit ihm zusammen ein großes Projekt starten.
[Klirren von Glas]
Das war Sarah mit ihrem Glas und dem Strohhälmchen.
Jedenfalls zeige ich ihn euch jetzt kurz.
Denn ich habe gesagt:
"Qais, du darfst dir eine Torte oder ein Rezept
oder irgendwas wünschen.
Sag es mir einfach."
Und er weiß nicht, dass er gleich vor die Kamera kommt.
Deswegen flüstere ich.
Der sitzt dahinten.
Kommt mal kurz mit.
Hi, Qais!
>> QAIS: Hi!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> QAIS: Soll ich halten?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und was machst du?
>> QAIS: Ich sitze gerade nur vor dem Computer.
Ich bin gerade erst gekommen.
Und...
>> SALLY: Was machen wir?
>> QAIS: Was machen wir beide?
>> SALLY: Ja, erzähl mal.
>> QAIS: Darf ich das so erzählen?
>> SALLY: Ja, komm, wir erzählen. Hau es raus.
Wir müssen ja nicht alles erzählen.
>> QAIS: Also wir arbeiten...
Sagen wir mal so: Wir arbeiten an der Geschichte
deines Lebens
beziehungsweise
wo du herkommst,
wie alles entstanden ist.
Und was genau daraus wird,
das werdet ihr dann
>> SALLY: erfahren.
>> QAIS: irgendwann erfahren.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Heute darfst du dir was wünschen
>> QAIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: und zwar ein Rezept.
Also wünsch dir was.
Ich bereite es dann vor.
>> QAIS: Okay.
Egal was?
>> SALLY: Egal was.
>> QAIS: Okay.
Wie lange darf es denn dauern?
>> SALLY: Egal. Vielleicht keine Harry-Potter-Motivtorte.
>> QAIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Bitte keine Harry-Potter-Motivtorte.
>> QAIS: Als ich in L.A. gelebt habe,
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: bin ich immer sehr gern
zur Cheesecake Factory gegangen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> QAIS: Und da gab es eine Torte,
die nennt sich Red Velvet Cheesecake.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> QAIS: Die ist...
Also die war echt richtig, richtig geil.
>> SALLY: Aber sehr süß auch und mächtig?
Oder so...
>> QAIS: Also es war sehr sahnig und sehr käsig.
Und...
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> QAIS: Also es war extrem süß auf jeden Fall.
Also es war eher Torte als Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann mache ich einen Red Velvet Cheesecake für Qais,
also einen Käskuchen für Qais.
>> QAIS: Also, wenn du das jetzt wirklich so hinbekommst,
wie es dort ist,
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> QAIS: das wäre schon ein Erlebnis.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, ob ich
– auf Google finde ich bestimmt Bilder
von der Cheesecake Factory
vom Red Velvet Cheesecake.
Dann gucke ich mir das Bild an.
Ich meine, ein Rezept steht da natürlich nicht dabei,
aber dann baue ich mir das halt zusammen.
Okay.
Ich komme in
vier Stunden wieder.
>> QAIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Chill solang.
>> QAIS: Okay, mache ich.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Also ihr habt es gehört.
Heute gibt es einen Red Velvet Cheesecake
wie in der Cheesecake Factory.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe den Red Velvet Cheesecake
dort noch nicht gegessen.
Ich hatte dort mal einen
Lemon Meringue Cheesecake gegessen.
Der Red Velvet, muss ich sagen, schmeckt bestimmt
mindestens genauso gut.
Ich hatte mal einen Red-Velvet-Kuchen
in meinem ersten Backbuch gemacht.
Und Red Velvet, der entstand ja auch so,
dass praktisch ein Schokoladenkuchen gemacht wurde
und in den Schokokuchen haben sie
Kakao und Essig gegeben.
Und der Kakao und der Essig, die reagieren dann
und dann entsteht diese rote Farbe.
Klar, mittlerweile macht man
da noch rote Lebensmittelfarbpaste mit rein,
weil man den Rotstich oder den Rotton
schon noch roter haben will als sonst.
Aber ansonsten ist es einfach ein schöner saftiger
und von der Konsistenz her samtiger Kuchen,
der jetzt hier die Basis für den Red Velvet Cheesecake wird.
Also ich bin mal gespannt.
Jetzt backe ich zuerst mal den Red-Velvet-Kuchen.
Dafür verwende ich
200 Gramm Butter,
– die ist bereits weich –
200 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
vier Eier,
– die sind auch schon zimmerwarm –
250 Gramm Mehl,
40 Gramm Kakao,
zwei Teelöffel Backpulver,
einen viertel Teelöffel Natron,
250 Gramm Buttermilch,
– die ist auch bereits auf Raumtemperatur –
50 Gramm Öl,
– da habe ich ein Sonnenblumenöl –
einen Esslöffel Essig
und rote Lebensmittelfarbpaste.
Ja, so viel dazu.
Wichtig ist, dass alle Zutaten zimmerwarm sind.
Den Ofen habe ich jetzt vorgeheizt
auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und ich mache jetzt den Kuchen in 24 cm Durchmesser.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier
– das ist jetzt eigentlich wie so ein normaler Rührkuchen,
so ein Marmorkuchenteig erst mal –
die weiche Butter in die Rührschüssel.
Dann kommt da der Zucker dazu,
eine Prise Salz
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Vanille ist hier auch ganz wichtig für den Geschmack.
[Musik]
Und dann wird die Masse jetzt hier
erst mal für fünf bis zehn Minuten richtig cremig verrührt.
Ich kann in der Zwischenzeit die trockenen Zutaten
einfach in mein Sieb einfüllen.
Die werden nämlich dann später dazu gesiebt.
Also die kann ich schon mal vermischen in der Zeit.
[Musik]
Wenn die Buttermasse dann so weißcremig aussieht,
jedes Ei einzeln dazu geben
und etwa eine halbe Minute einrühren.
Wenn ihr das Ganze zu schnell macht,
kann es nämlich passieren, dass der Teig krisselig wird.
Ist bestimmt auch schon mal passiert.
Und wirklich auch wichtig,
dass die zimmerwarm sind und nicht zu kalt.
[Musik]
Und jetzt gebe ich einfach alle restlichen Zutaten dazu.
Ich mache jetzt auch kurz die Maschine aus.
Wie gesagt, die trockenen Zutaten sieben,
damit die nicht klumpen.
Und dann werde ich alles nur noch kurz verrühren.
Denn das solltet ihr auch wissen:
Wenn Mehl in den Teig kommt,
dann wirklich nur noch kurz verrühren,
bis sich alles verbunden hat,
damit der Kuchen später nicht matschig und speckig wird.
[Musik]
Jetzt bei niedriger Stufe verrühren.
Und dann gebe ich nach und nach noch die Farbpaste dazu.
Ich nehme da ja seit Jahren die Decocino Farbpaste.
Dekoback, Decocino, so hieß es früher.
Und die Farbpaste ist ohne Azofarbstoffe.
Das heißt, da sind einfach keine krebserregende Stoffe drin.
Azofarben müssen nämlich gekennzeichnet werden.
Und gerade im Supermarkt, im Lebensmittelhandel
sind die eben nicht mehr erlaubt.
Deswegen sind die ohne
und daher eben auch unbedenklich.
[Musik]
Der muss jetzt auch gar nicht knallrot aussehen.
Denn die Farbe, die kommt jetzt im rohen Zustand
gar nicht so gut raus, muss ich sagen, im Teig,
aber, wenn es gleich gebacken ist, umso besser.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich den Teig jetzt hier einfüllen.
Und ihr seht, die Konsistenz ist jetzt nicht so dünnflüssig
wie bei einem Rührteig mit Öl.
Daher kann ich jetzt den Teig einfach so reinfüllen,
ohne dass ich den Backring in Backpapier einschlagen muss.
Ansonsten, wenn er jetzt flüssiger wäre,
muss ich sagen, würde ich ihn jetzt einschlagen.
Aber so geht es.
Also so bei Biskuit und bei Rührteig mit Butter
muss man es echt nicht machen.
[Musik]
Dann kurz verteilen.
Und gern am Rand so ein bisschen höher streichen
als in der Mitte.
Dann geht er noch gleichmäßiger auf.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen,
wird gebacken.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
kümmere ich mich schon mal um die Cheesecake-Füllung,
um den Cheesecake.
[Musik]
Für die Cheesecake-Füllung habe ich jetzt
so eine Abwandlung gemacht
von meinem New York Cheesecake.
Da ist ja auch die Füllung schön cremig.
Ich denke, genau so schmeckt es auch.
Dafür nehme ich
350 Gramm Frischkäse in Doppelrahmstufe,
100 Gramm Puderzucker,
10 Gramm Stärke,
Vanilleextrakt,
drei Eier
und 200 Gramm saure Sahne.
Und das geht jetzt ganz einfach.
Ihr verrührt nämlich alle Zutaten cremig,
aber nicht luftig,
also nicht auf höchster Stufe und mit dem Schneebesen,
sondern wirklich nur cremig rühren.
Denn das Ganze soll ja nicht aufgehen
oder luftig sein.
[Musik]
So. Und jetzt nur kurz verrühren,
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat.
[Musik]
Ich habe einen Fehler gemacht.
Am besten verrührt ihr zuerst den Frischkäse
mit dem Puderzucker cremig.
Denn, wenn man den Frischkäse direkt
mit den anderen flüssigen Zutaten verrührt,
dann wird er flockig.
Ja.
Aber ich versuche es jetzt kurz mit dem Schneebesen.
Wenn nicht, nehme ich kurz den Pürierstab.
Also, wie gesagt, erst Frischkäse mit Puderzucker.
Weil guck, so wie jetzt hier.
Seht ihr die kleinen Flocken?
Das soll natürlich nicht sein.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Füllung schön cremig.
Jetzt nehme ich noch mal einen Tortenring.
Wieder 24 cm.
Das darf gern gleich groß sein.
Den schlage ich jetzt aber in Backpapier ein,
weil es ja wirklich ein flüssige Masse ist.
[Musik]
Und den backe ich jetzt auf zwei Mal.
Also einfach halbieren.
Ich kann das jetzt hier an der Schüssel ablesen.
Ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach
noch mal eine frische Schüssel
oder wiegt eben die Masse raus.
Ihr habt ja das Gesamtgewicht
der Creme.
Ein bisschen noch.
[Musik]
So.
Und das wird dann auf zwei Mal gebacken.
Da macht es jetzt auch nichts, wenn das hier steht.
Da ist ja kein Backpulver drin.
[Musik]
Dann kurz klopfen,
damit die Luft entweicht.
Und jetzt im Backofen backen,
nicht bei 170°C, sondern 130°C.
Der soll nämlich nicht dunkel werden
und einfach nur durchgaren.
Und danach backe ich den zweiten.
[Musik]
Mh.
Hätte man auch bei Heißluft backen können.
Dann könnt ihr beide gleichzeitig backen.
So mache ich es.
Kurz noch den zweiten einfüllen.
Und dann bei Heißluft.
Ich mache den Cheesecake jetzt doch in 22 cm Größe.
Ich habe es einfach kurz zusammengeschoben,
damit die Cheesecake-Füllung
zum einen ein bisschen dicker wird
und ein bisschen kleiner wird als der Kuchen an sich
und später nicht rausguckt.
[Musik]
Es ist immer so schwierig, hier zu drehen,
wenn ich hier sitze
– hier stehe und drehe und moderiere
und Murat auf der Couch sitzt
und Storys schaut
mit Ton
in meinem Hintergrund.
Wer Krach macht, muss auch winken.
Jetzt in den Backofen.
Hm.
So.
Jetzt sind sie gleichzeitig fertig dann.
Und jetzt machen wir mal 120°C Heißluft.
[Musik]
Schaut mal. Der Cheesecake ist schön hell gebacken
und abgekühlt.
Der kommt jetzt ins Gefrierfach, damit er schön kalt wird.
Und während der jetzt einfriert und der Kuchen auskühlt,
kann ich schon mal die Cream-Cheese-Masse machen,
also ein Cream Cheese Vanilla Frosting.
Für das Cream Cheese Frosting nehme ich
300 Butter,
– die ist weich –
180 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
300 Gramm Frischkäse
und 250 Gramm Quark.
Ich muss dazu sagen:
Eigentlich mache ich ein Frischkäse-
– eine Frischkäse-Buttercreme
immer zu gleichen Teilen,
das heißt Butter, Puderzucker, Frischkäse zu gleichen Teilen.
Also, wenn ich jetzt 300 Gramm Butter habe,
300 Gramm Frischkäse,
hätte ich auch 300 Gramm Puderzucker gebraucht.
Aber ich muss sagen,
diese amerikanischen Torten sind mir oft zu süß.
Deswegen mache ich es ein bisschen deutscher,
weil die Deutschen eigentlich auch nicht so süß essen
und gern mit weniger Zucker.
Also habe ich ein bisschen Puderzucker raus
und noch einen Quark rein.
Dann machen wir das Ganze mal ein bisschen light.
Denn ich denke,
300 Gramm Butter
>> JOSH: Light?!
>> SALLY: und 300 Gramm Frischkäse
reichen auf jeden Fall aus.
Aber hey, komm.
Im Vergleich zu einem typisch amerikanischen Rezept
– also ich habe mir mal andere angeguckt
und da war für dieses Rezept 400 Gramm Puderzucker
angedacht.
Und für die ist ja eine Buttercreme Butter und Puderzucker
so im Normalfall.
Und ich glaube, die Light-Version ist
Butter, Puderzucker, Frischkäse.
Okay. Butter, Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt
schön cremig rühren.
Und, wie gesagt, darauf achten,
dass die Zutaten zimmerwarm sind.
Ich habe kurz überlegt: "Spritzschutz,
ja oder nein?"
Die Antwort war Ja.
>> JOSH: Guck, die Antwort ist richtig.
>> SALLY: Die Antwort ist ups.
[Musik]
Die Butter-Puderzucker-Masse jetzt einfach
etwa fünf bis zehn Minuten cremig aufschlagen,
sodass sie wirklich so ein bisschen weißcremig wird.
Und dann gebe ich esslöffelweise
den Frischkäse und den Quark dazu.
[Musik]
Die Creme hat jetzt eine echt schöne Konsistenz.
Die ist aber jetzt ein bisschen zu warm.
Ich decke sie kurz ab, stelle sie in den Kühlschrank
und dann können wir gleich,
wenn die Creme so ein bisschen kühl ist,
die Torte füllen.
[Musik]
Der Red-Velvet-Boden ist jetzt schön kalt,
die Cheesecakes sind gefroren,
die Creme ist kalt.
Alles perfekt.
Der Kuchen, der fällt so ein bisschen zusammen.
Das ist aber gar nicht schlimm.
Der hat eben diese samtige Textur
und nicht so eine lockere
– wie sage ich da? –
Schwammtextur,
also nicht so ein Sponge Cake,
sondern wirklich so ein eher
cremiger, samtiger Kuchen.
Den halbiere ich jetzt kurz.
[Musik]
So.
Den oberen nehme ich weg.
Ja.
Dann muss ich immer ein bisschen spicken.
Denn ich habe da drüben
ein Bild von der Cheesecake Factory.
Und ich will es ja original.
Ich nehme jetzt einen Spritzbeutel,
habe hier so eine 12-mm-Lochtülle.
Noch vorher die Spitze wegschneiden.
Okay, noch ein bisschen.
Und dann einfach umknicken
und im Spritzbeutelständer platzieren.
So.
Dann fällt da unten auch nichts raus.
[Musik]
Also ich muss sagen, bisher die Creme
sieht auch aus wie bei der Cheesecake Factory.
So eine schöne, schöne Textur.
Okay.
Boden,
Creme,
Cheesecake,
Boden.
Man sieht es kaum.
Also ein bisschen Creme an den Boden,
also eher so eine dünne Schicht.
[Musik]
Vielleicht mache ich den aber auch naked,
also gar nicht
umschlossen.
Deswegen, ich gucke mal, wie es gleich aussieht.
Das machen wir spontan.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich einen Boden rauslösen.
Okay, die sind jetzt nicht ganz durchgefroren.
Aber ich werde es hinkriegen.
O Gott!
Also wichtig ist echt, dass die gefroren sind,
damit ihr es gut als Platte drauf kriegt.
Oder ihr macht die Risikovariante
so wie ich.
So.
Okay, das ist jetzt echt nicht ganz so schön geworden,
weil es nicht ganz gefroren war.
Wie gesagt, lasst es gut einfrieren.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen schmierig.
Denn die Textur von diesem Käsekuchen ist ja sehr cremig.
Und dann kriegt ihr das nicht kalt drauf,
sondern wirklich nur gefroren als Platte.
Aber ich habe jetzt den zweiten noch mal eingefroren.
Bis dahin mache ich den hier fertig.
Hier noch mal eine Creme drüber.
[Musik]
Und drunter eher eine dünnere Schicht
und drüber dann eine dickere Cremeschicht.
Und ich lasse jetzt aber ganz kurz
den Cheesecake ein bisschen gefroren,
dass ich den zumindest schön drauflegen kann.
Und die Torte stelle ich solang in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Es sind halt wenige Minuten, die hier entscheiden.
Okay, die Technik war doch nicht so gut.
Mein Boden war doch nicht so
gefroren, wie ich ursprünglich dachte.
Ich kriege das hin.
Es ist okay, dass man das auch mal
– dass man auch mal einen Fail sieht.
Ist schon mal was nicht gelungen?
Ja.
>> JOSH: Oreo-Kekse?
>> SALLY: Pst!
Pack jetzt hier nicht die alten Dinge aus.
Oh! Ich drehe sie schnell wieder weg.
Der Qais wird so enttäuscht sein.
>> JOSH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Es tut mir
– mein Gott! Ich habe halt nicht warten können,
bis das Ding einfriert.
Wisst ihr, wir stehen seit heute Morgen um acht hier
und ich habe Hunger und es ist 14 Uhr
und wir haben zwischendrin echt vieles gemacht.
Ich kriege das voll schön.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, Hauptsache, es schmeckt gut.
>> SALLY: Ha ja.
Und außerdem
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich ein bisschen Sahne haben?
>> SALLY: Nee, Schatz. Die brauche ich tatsächlich noch.
Weil, ich glaube, es reicht gerade knapp.
Aber, wenn was übrig bleibt, dann gebe ich dir.
Kannst du mir vielleicht eine Edelstahlteigkarte geben?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also angesichts der Tatsache
– ich mache keinen Naked Cheesecake,
habe ich jetzt gerade mit dem Josh
einvernehmlich beschlossen.
>> SAMIRA: Damit geht sie da so drüber und wiu.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich wollte eigentlich einen Naked Cake machen
>> SAMIRA: Was ist ein Naked Cake?
>> SALLY: Ein nackter Kuchen.
Ja, den backt man ja nicht nackt,
der Kuchen sieht nur nackt aus.
Also so wäre er ein Naked Cake.
Wenn man das schön macht, dann sieht es auch schön aus.
Wisst ihr, es ist nicht schlimm, wenn mal was nicht klappt.
Ihr müsst nur wissen, wie ihr es versteckt.
Ja.
Und ich gebe jetzt den Kuchen in den Kühlschrank.
Wir essen endlich unser Mittagessen.
Und danach zeige ich euch,
wie ihr diesen Kuchen schön dekoriert.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, das war das unsatis-
– das...
Wie sagt man?
Du weißt, was ich sagen will?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der am wenigsten elegant aussehendste Kuchen
bei der Zubereitung.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die Creme war ja jetzt auch im Kühlschrank.
Die Torte war im Kühlschrank.
Jetzt lässt sie sich prima verstreichen.
Ich muss sagen, ich hoffe sehr,
dass sie innen trotzdem so schön aussieht,
wie ich sie mir vorstelle.
Bestimmt.
Und schmecken tut sie bestimmt auch.
Wie gesagt, bei der Zubereitung hat es heute ein bisschen
ein bisschen gehangen.
Macht nichts.
Außen dann mit einer Teigkarte glatt ziehen.
Und außen
– das habe ich auch
beim Cheesecake-Factory-Kuchen gesehen.
Ich meine, ich kann den jetzt auch auf Sally-Style machen,
aber so ein bisschen optisch will ich ihn schon auch anpassen.
Da möchte ich außen gleich noch
aus weißer Schokolade Raspeln machen.
Und die kommen noch außen drauf.
So. Letzte Runde.
Letzte Runde, Runde, Runde
im Karussell.
So.
Dann,
damit wirklich nichts übrig bleibt,
so, hier noch mal drauf.
Und die Oberfläche mache ich jetzt auch leicht marmoriert.
[Musik]
Und dann
also so ein bisschen wellig erst mal.
Dann kommt die Torte noch mal kurz in den Kühlschrank,
dass sie so ein bisschen fest werden kann.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
aus weißer Kuvertüre Schokoladenröllchen machen.
Und die Kuvertüre habe ich jetzt auch
schon kurz ins Gefrierfach gelegt.
Dann geht es nämlich einfacher.
[Musik]
Die weißen Schokoladenröllchen mache ich jetzt hier
mit einem Sparschäler.
Einfach weiße Kuvertüre nehmen
und so ein bisschen drüberschaben.
Und, wie gesagt, vorher kurz einfrieren
oder in den Kühlschrank stellen,
damit sie einfach schön kalt ist.
Die Folie lasse ich auch meist dran,
damit einfach die Schokolade nicht in der Hand schmilzt.
[Musik]
Schaut mal. Jetzt nehmt ihr diese schönen Röllchen
mit einer Teigkarte am besten auf.
Denn mit den Händen würdet ihr sie zum einen zerdrücken
und zum anderen schmelzen die ja auch.
Und jetzt einfach ganz vorsichtig hier so dran
von unten nach oben.
[Musik]
Erinnert mich immer so an eine Schwarzwälder Kirsch.
Ursprünglich sollte es ja auch ein Naked Cake werden.
Jetzt ist er halt half naked, sagt man dazu.
Es ist echt so.
>> JOSH: Bikini Cake.
>> SALLY: Der ist der Bikini Cake.
Ich war vorhin an einem Punkt, da dachte ich so:
"Okay.
Aus dem Cheesecake wird
– werden Cakepops,
Red Velvet Cheesecake Cakepops
aus der Cheesecake Factory."
Aber jetzt muss ich sagen:
Doch, gefällt mir gut,
wenn ich die jetzt noch hier umsetze.
[Musik]
Ha ja.
So.
Sieht schon gut aus.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das die von vorhin?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich habe ja gesagt,
es muss nicht immer alles perfekt gelingen,
man muss es nur perfekt kaschieren können.
Cool, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Das Muster dort obendrauf sieht voll gut aus.
>> SALLY: Ich würde sagen,
ich lasse den Qais probieren
und er sagt mir, ob der Kuchen so schmeckt
wie in der Cheesecake Factory.
Ich bin gespannt
und ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Nach anfänglichen Missgeschicken
doch ans Ziel gekommen.
[Musik]
Stunde der Wahrheit.
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich bin gespannt.
Ich hätte vor zwei Stunden nicht gedacht,
dass ich an den Punkt
gelangen würde.
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Kurz habe ich überlegt,
Cakepops daraus zu machen.
>> QAIS: Aber es sieht schon sehr, sehr gut aus.
>> SALLY: Was hier wichtig ist, denke ich,
also mein Empfinden,
>> QAIS: Ja?
>> SALLY: dass man den nicht zu kalt isst.
>> QAIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen, ich habe jetzt nicht nach...
So sieht er aus.
>> QAIS: Oh, der sieht ganz genauso aus.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: Ja, hundertprozentig.
Vor allem diese Schichten. Ja.
>> SALLY: Aufgestellt oder hingelegt?
>> QAIS: Wie du magst.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm, ich stelle ihn dir auf.
>> QAIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich habe ja auch original nach Foto gearbeitet.
>> QAIS: Sieht echt cool aus.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube nur,
dass ich es weniger süß gemacht habe als in Amerika.
>> QAIS: Ja,
>> SALLY: Weil die haben schon
>> QAIS: wahrscheinlich.
>> SALLY: immer sehr viel Zucker.
>> QAIS: Das zum Beispiel wäre wahrscheinlich so
von der Portion her ein Drittel von dem, was die servieren.
>> SALLY: Also ich weiß noch,
als wir in der Cheesecake Factory damals waren,
ich habe zwei Stück Kuchen gekauft für 18 Dollar.
Also nicht zwei ganze,
zwei Kuchenstücke.
Aber man konnte auch
– wir haben das dann zu fünft oder zu sechst gegessen.
>> QAIS: Das ist so gut!
>> QAIS: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: Das ist genauso wie drüben.
Boah, ich fühle mich gerade wie in L.A.!
>> SALLY: Yeah, welcome in L.A.!
>> QAIS: Das ist richtig, richtig, richtig gut.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich wollte noch so einen Gangsterspruch bringen,
aber dann dachte ich so: "Sally, lass es."
>> QAIS: Hey, den musst du probieren.
Das ist echt lecker.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
Ist die Cheesecake-Füllung, also die Cheesecake-Creme
– ich sehe schon, die ist sehr cremig, gell?
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wow! Deswegen...
>> QAIS: Also die haben es drüben auf jeden Fall
viel kälter.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: Es ist, also es ist fester insgesamt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> QAIS: Aber ich finde es so viel einfacher zum Essen.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, also ich hatte den jetzt
auch noch nicht so lange in der Kühlung, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich denke, wenn der so bis morgen
im Kühlschrank steht, dann...
Ja, aber ich mag es auch nicht zu kalt.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde, die Aromen sind besser.
>> QAIS: Ich finde es so perfekt.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> QAIS: Genauso wie letztes Mal bei dem
– was war das?
Peanutbutter?
>> SALLY: Oh! Peanutbutter Cheesecake.
>> QAIS: Genau.
>> QAIS: Da fand ich auch die
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> QAIS: die Temperatur auch besser, als
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> QAIS: wenn es zu kalt ist.
Also sehr gut.
Ich bin richtig happy.
>> QAIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Wie gesagt, beim Zubereiten
der Cheesecake-Füllung
– ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe es ja vorher noch nicht gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man den komplett einfrieren kann.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Probiert es einfach aus.
Wenn nicht, nehmt ihr einfach die Technik,
die ich genommen habe,
mit den Händen.
Und dann klappt das schon.
Also vielen Dank für deinen Rezeptwunsch.
>> QAIS: Danke für den Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Ich bin voll happy.
>> QAIS: Sehr, sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Und wir nehmen uns jetzt noch eine Tasse Kaffee
und dann schreiben wir weiter.
Ja.
Das Rezept gibt es auf sallys-blog.de.
Tschüss!
>> QAIS: Tschau!
>> SALLY: Und wenn ihr Rezeptwünsche habt,
schreibt sie gern in die Kommentare.
Dann mache ich nämlich
den Rezeptwunsch meiner Zuschauer nach
und erwähne euch dann im Video,
von wem das der Wunsch war.
Josh, du bist auch noch dran
mit Wunsch.
Er überlegt so jeden Tag:
"Woah, Nougat!
Woah, frittieren!"
Ja, wir wissen es nicht.
Ich lasse mich überraschen.
>> JOSH: Ich habe noch eine Idee gehabt.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Juhu!
Okay, ich bin gespannt.
Tschüss!
So.
Typischerweise laufen wir jetzt immer raus.
Wir wissen nicht warum, aber wir laufen immer aus der Küche.
Wir haben es uns so – keine Ahnung.
>> QAIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und dann bleibe ich meist hier so stehen,
warte, bis der Josh mit der Kamera aufhört.
Und dann: "Okay, aufräumen."
Warum laufen wir immer aus dem Bild?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht. Das ist eine gute Frage.
>> SALLY: Es hat sich so eingebürgert.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> QAIS: Boah, Sally, das ist so lecker, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja? Du kannst ruhig ehrlich sein.
>> QAIS: Ich meine es ernst!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> QAIS: Das ist übertrieben lecker!
Und das ist genauso süß, wie die es drüben haben.
>> SALLY: Wuh!
Sehr gut!
Aber nicht zu süß?
>> QAIS: Nein!
>> SALLY: Gut.
>> QAIS: Aber es ist perfekt.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich gönne mir jetzt auch ein Stück.
[Musik]